[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de la
retraite La retraite à quel âge réformer
les retraites est un vieux serpent de
mer de la politique nationale pour s'en
tenir au 30 dernières années il eut la
réforme Balladur en 1993 la réforme
Fillon en 2004 la réforme verte 2010 la
réforme Touraine sous la présidence de
François Hollande et la réforme avortée
de janvier 2020 sous la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron rebelote en 2022 avec
un nouveau projet de réforme des
retraites moins ambitieux comme on le
verra mais en but au même tabou le
fameux âges de départ à 65 ans le monde
syndical est vent debout contre cette
mesure et ils préparent je le cite une
opposition frontale avec le concours des
forces politiques d'opposition alors que
la présidente de la République
souhaitait réformé les retraites sans
tarder de sa propre majorité se sont
élevés des voix contre un passage en
force et nous revoilà dans le temps de
la concertation avant qu'un projet de
loi soit discuté au Parlement 2023 pour
quelle réforme quelle compromis et bien
sûr quel âge de départ c'est ce que nous
allons voir avec nos invités Jean-Claude
Mahy vous êtes ancien secrétaire général
de Force Ouvrière Michel diayel
directeur des politiques sociales à
Caisse des Dépôts Jean-François Copé
vous êtes ancien ministre et avocat et
Jean de kervas Doha économiste de la
santé à l'Académie des technologies
[Musique]
alors en 2020 il était question d'une
réforme systémique unifiant les régimes
de base et les régimes complémentaires
il n'est plus question désormais de ce
qu'on appelle des mesures paramétriques
pourquoi il serait utopique d'avoir un
régime universel des régimes de base à
la place des 42 régimes de base comme
c'est le cas avec comme c'était le cas
avec la sécurité c'est toujours le cas
avec la sécurité sociale de 1945 Michel
le général de Gaulle a quitté ses
fonctions en janvier 46 et quelques
semaines après intervenait le premier
texte qui crée les régimes spéciaux de
retraite c'est dire l'élasticité du
système la première chose qui est
trouvée à faire les grands réformateurs
de l'époque je rappelle que la sécurité
sociale a été créée par une ordonnance
d'octobre 1945 ça a été malgré tout de
conserver la spécificité des régimes qui
existait alors ce qui veut dire qu'ils
sont ancrés dans le paysage et d'un
autre côté ce que je dis n'est pas un
assaut d'amabilité envers spéciaux c'est
simplement la réalité quand vous avez 42
régimes dont 4 parlementaires et que
vous leur proposez de se transformer en
main disons que la probabilité que ça se
passe bien n'est pas spontanée voilà
donc probablement que la marche était un
peu haute entre le système que nous
gérons aujourd'hui et dans sa complexité
un peu dramatique et puis un système
idéal unique égal ou égalitaire en tout
cas pour tous les Français et universel
dans sa dans sa conception il fallait
peut-être des étapes et ne pas les avoir
respecté a pu même si le problème était
plutôt politique autre chose aboutir à
ce résultat voilà c'est adhérer
Jean-François Copé pourquoi ce qui est
vrai avec la sécurité sociale ne serait
pas avec les retraites au moins pour les
régimes de base parce que ça s'appelle
le pragmatisme
vous avez bien fait de rappeler
l'historique 1946
ne doit pas oublier que c'était un
cogestion de la France entre les
gaullistes et les communistes il fallait
faire un grand pacte de réconciliation
et à l'époque tenir compte de la
puissance du Parti communiste notamment
à la SNCF et c'est ce qui explique que
ou à EDF qui a eu tous ces régimes
spécifiques pour en tenir compte et puis
c'est vrai que c'était une toute autre
époque pour mille raisons moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la situation est
tellement préoccupante qu'on ne peut pas
arriver avec des réponses complexes on
peut pas ouvrir tous les fronts à la
fois et de ce point de vue on est tous
arrivé en tout cas quand on est
responsable de gouvernement ou qu'on l'a
été cette idée que face à un problème
qu'il lève toutes les oppositions les
plus brillantes il n'y a d'autres
solutions de proposer la formule la plus
simple et il est apparu que la formule
la plus simple et sans doute la plus
efficace d'ailleurs c'était l'âge légal
et c'est pour ça qu'après avoir tout
essayé on en arrive aujourd'hui à
l'essentiel il faut bouger là je légale
comme ça se fait dans tous les pays
d'Europe bah alors s'il faut bouger
large légal Jean-Claude Mahy aujourd'hui
l'âge moyen et
63,3 ans il y a des fluctuations
naturellement mais de
63,3 à 65 ans pourquoi ça fait figure
d'épouvantail alors que c'est largement
usage dans tout le temps de nombreux
pays européens et non donne moi dans de
nombreuses démocraties juste à Moïse ces
différentes la santé et la retraite
parce que la santé au fil du temps la
couverture santé est devenue quelque
chose d'universel que vous soyez salarié
ou non salarié que la retraite sa
demeure quelque chose qu'on appelle un
système contributif c'est-à-dire vous
payez des cotisations
qui rentrent dans le cadre de la
répartition de la solidarité en même
temps vous vous acquérez des droits donc
il y a une différence entre les deux
alors ensuite c'est vrai que si on
hypothèse on ne change rien au système
actuel je dis pas que c'est ce qu'il
faut faire mais si on ne change rien
compte tenu des règles actuelles
quelqu'un qui est né en 1973 qui
commence à cotiser à l'âge de 21 ans ce
qui n'est pas le cas de tout le monde
partira à taux plein à 64 ans donc on
peut se dire quel est le problème en
même temps d'âge sauf qu'il faut
comprendre que la France à la différence
de pays a moins joué sur l'âge en fait
c'est passé de 60 à 62 on a plus joué
sur la durée de cotisation
historiquement donc et d'ailleurs c'est
ces jours-ci le président de la
République a lui-même dit ah mais si
c'est pas 65 ça peut être 64 à condition
qu'on allonge la durée de cotisation
mais en même temps il y a c'est un faux
débat en fait le problème qu'il se pose
aujourd'hui c'est essentiellement un
problème budgétaire à partir du moment
où la France doit respecter ses
engagements européens donc ça veut dire
3% de déficit budgétaire à l'horizon de
2027 qu'on a une série d'interventions
budgétaires il faut de faire des
économies or les économies on veut les
faire où on veut les faire avec la
retraite moins qu'on pense d'ailleurs
parce que ce qu'on économise en reculant
l'âge on a des dépenses supplémentaires
sur la santé etc ou sur le chômage sur
l'assurance chômage sur les
collectivités territoriales et sur
l'état donc on est plus sur une
réflexion aujourd'hui selon moi qui est
de caractère budgétaire que
fondamentalement
réflexion sur la retraite et d'une
certaine manière position personnelle
mais considère que dans tous les cas de
figure quel que soit la méthode choisie
mais on sait bien que Victor Hugo
expliquait que la méthode c'est le fond
qui remonte à la surface quel que soit
la méthode choisie aujourd'hui c'est un
piège pour un gouvernement
Jean de Ker va se à l'économiste de la
santé que vous êtes mais vous avez été
aussi directeur des hôpitaux la ville de
Paris vous pensez que cette réforme des
retraites n'a qu'un versant économique
non pas du tout je pense que je pense
que des
c'est que la question centrale à mon
avis n'est pas du tout cela la question
centrale c'est comment ne pénalise-t-on
pas trop les actifs compte tenu de la
démographie alors il faut rappeler en
deux mots que il s'est produit un
accident démographique qui est la
génération du baby-boom que la
génération de baby-boom elle commence en
47 elle s'arrête en 73 et qu'en
politique sociale est à trois âges
importants il y a l'âge de la retraite
sur lequel je vais revenir il y a 70 ans
qui est l'âge moyen à l'hôpital parce
qu'on oublie que la santé c'est une
affaire de vieux
et que donc le système de financement
des actifs pour la retraite c'est aussi
le système financement des actifs pour
la santé et pour les actifs financent
aussi les plus jeunes ça c'est par le
biais par le biais des impôts donc la
question est de savoir jusqu'où peut-on
charger les épaules les jeunes des
Jeunes Actifs alors sachant que par
ailleurs en 60 1960 l'espérance de vie
était 62 ans que l'âge de la retraite
était 65 ans et que le rapport d'actifs
sur les retraités c'était de 4
aujourd'hui
l'espérance l'âge de la retraite et
celle qu'on en a dit
l'espérance de vie et de 82 ans et le
rapport d'actif sur la retraités donc on
est complètement fou quand on quand on
se pense que c'est une pardon de dire ça
de manière aussi brutale mais il est
très étonnant pour moi parce que de dire
que c'est uniquement une question
d'argent c'est pas vrai c'est-à-dire que
c'est une question de solidarité
sachant que je vais m'arrêter là que à
l'âge de 25 ans la moitié des Français
ne travaille pas encore et à l'âge de 60
ans la moitié des Français ne
travaillent plus donc on a un énorme
système de redistribution et ça se voit
quand on voit la transformation des
permis des âges on a un énorme logiciel
de distribution des actifs sur les
retraités sur les inactifs donc on peut
pas garder pour des raisons encore une
fois parce que on se passionne nous en
France sur
le partage de la richesse
à mon avis le problème central
aujourd'hui c'est la production dans les
chaises
l'emploi là j'ai fait récemment parce
que je tiens une chronique dans le
journal le point sur
le drame de l'agriculture française on
va rentrer je voudrais éclaircir un
point de vous venez de citer quelque
chose qui remet en cause le propos
Jean-Claude Mahy et là je voudrais
savoir Jean-Claude Mahy est-ce que le
syndicaliste que vous êtes
ignore ce que vient de dire maintenant
Jean de kervazouer c'est que les
pyramides des
âges de la vie du travail etc
sont j'allais dire une démonstration
qu'il faut bouger
cette ce départ l'âge de départ je ne
connais pas rentrer dans ce qu'il
faudrait faire je conteste pas les
choses ce que je dis simplement c'est
que pour respecter son programme
jusqu'en 2027 qu'il doit transmettre à
Bruxelles il y a 75 milliards
d'économies à faire alors quand on
regarde ce que prévoit le gouvernement
dans les 75 milliards il y a les
retraites l'assurance chômage les
collectivités territoires donc ça c'est
le problème immédiat on peut discuter
oui c'est un des aspects c'est un des
aspects du problème maintenant vous
savez moi
par rapport à la pyramide des âges ce
problème je ne nie pas ça on peut
regarder les choses mais moi je rappelle
souvent et je rappelais souvent quand
j'étais en responsabilité syndicale moi
ce que je considère comme le meilleur
discours sur la protection sociale je
dis pas que c'est je connais pas tous
mais c'est celui de Daniel Meyer en 1949
à l'Assemblée nationale à l'époque quand
on a créé la sécurité sociale après les
ordonnances de 45
beaucoup y compris l'Assemblée nationale
criait à la faillite du système à la
faillite de l'économie qu'on a jamais
pouvoir faire or on a fait les choses
bon alors après qu'il faille bouger des
curseurs vous le disiez tout à l'heure
là je moyen de liquidation aujourd'hui
il est de 63,3 ans bon et 64 pour les
futurs générations donc en même temps là
c'est un faux problème maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous dites que là j'ai un
faux problème oui parce que dans les
faits on est déjà 64 ans on va être à 64
ans pourquoi 65 c'est le tabou non mais
parce que attendez pourquoi le président
de la République il a annoncé 65 pendant
la campagne présidentielle
dans quelques années d'accord mais il a
fait ça à l'époque selon moi pour des
raisons politiciennes pour pouvoir jouer
dans le con le résultat d'une élection
présidentielle on est sur autre chose on
n'est pas dans la logique d'un système
de retrait qu'on est dans une logique
politicienne donc mettons ça de compter
il a pris un engagement mais en même
temps il faut être pragmatique
aujourd'hui vous avez une situation où
toutes les syndicale sans exception
refusent quand je dis que c'est le piège
ce dossier imaginez ce qui n'a pas été
le cas qui l'aurait décidé de passer
tout de suite au pffs ce qui était
envisageable à un moment donné
il serait il sera arrivé dans quel
contexte avec le avec les grèves dans
les raffineries ça risquait de faire
l'étincelle là on a trois mois de
consultation concertation consultation
etc début d'année ont annoncé ce qu'ils
veulent faire début d'année il y aura
l'augmentation du gaz augmentation de
l'électricité il y aura d'autres
problèmes voilà c'est le dossier
infernal mais parce que je moi on en
reviendra mais je considère qu'on le
prend par le mauvais bout oui
Jean-François Copé moi ce qui est vrai
c'est que en entendant cet échange
Jean-Claude Mahy et Monsieur de
kervezzou et ça m'a rajeuni en fait
puisque nous avons exactement eu les
mêmes discussions en 2003 j'étais à
l'époque au gouvernement nous avons eu
les mêmes discussions en 2010 c'était
l'époque était de la majorité à
l'Assemblée et à chaque fois on est
arrivé au même blocage et puis il y a
des gouvernements qui tiennent pas le
tout après le rituel du cauchemar
pendant des mois et des mois de blocage
de grève etc il y a donc évidemment un
problème de méthode mais moi j'arrive
pas à la même conclusion que Jean-Claude
Mahy moi je vais vous dire une chose en
fait je pense que chacun est dans son
rôle et que les intérêts sont pas
alignés sur ce sujet je pense que ils
sont alignés entre les syndicats le
patronat et le gouvernement pour
discuter réforme du chômage réforme de
la santé il y a de quoi trouver des
points de convergence sur les retraites
il y en aura jamais sur le faut arrêter
de se mentir il n'y en aura jamais pour
une raison très simple c'est que pour
toute une série de raisons les
partenaires sociaux ne vont jamais se
mettre d'accord la seule mesure faut
arrêter de tourner autour du pot et vous
avez bien fait de rappeler les chiffres
on les a bien en tête arrêtons de
tourner autour du pot la seule solution
c'est qu'à partir du moment où on vit
plus longtemps on rentre plus tard sur
le marché du travail il faut allonger
l'âge légal juste attendez pour terminer
là-dessus
le fond va avec la méthode en fait si on
veut y arriver et ben c'est la noblesse
du politique que de dire écouté j'ai été
élu au suffrage universel je vais donc
prendre la décision et je ne peux pas la
prendre après des concertations qui ont
déjà eu lieu mille fois et dont la plus
grande des concertations c'est la
campagne présidentielle ou les Français
savaient qu'en réalisant Emmanuel Macron
cette réforme serait sur la table le
seul fait de dire on va encore
rediscuter va évidemment n'aboutira
aucun
consensusiez quelque chose
je demanderai la vie des autres
intervenants vous avez laissé
sous-entendre que sur les retraites il
était impossible de se mettre impossible
Pierre Mendès France disait que quand on
prenait l'histoire des impôts en France
c'était l'histoire de la France est-ce
que vous diriez que c'est pareil pour
les retraites c'est à dire que c'est
plein de lobby qui ont agi à différents
moments et en favorisant différents
régimes et que c'est la raison pour
laquelle on peut pas bouger puis à
modeste réaliser aussi gouverner c'est
choisir je vais vous dire une chose tout
ce que vous dites est vrai le poids de
l'histoire moi j'ai rebondi sur ce que
vous disiez et très lourd dans l'affaire
des retraites comme d'ailleurs de tout
notre modèle social sauf qu'il y a un
moment où la grandeur du politique c'est
de dire maintenant j'ai entendu tout le
monde je sais qu'il n'y aura pas
d'accord ma responsabilité politique
c'est d'assumer une décision mais il
faut pas la prendre sans la prendre en
faisant semblant en faisant des vraies
fausses concertation alors qu'on sait
que cette seule mesure d'âge va
permettre de tenir le choc de cette
situation donc au lieu de partir sur des
lois qui n'en finiront jamais des
discussions qui ne se feront pas la
seule solution était de le faire dès
l'élection en réalité et pas par un
amendement par une ordonnance et le dire
aux Français et à ce moment-là il
appartenait aux partenaires sociaux dès
l'automne et de la loi ayant été adoptée
par ordonnance de faire ce travail
d'évaluation et de et de s'appeler à
d'autres sujets difficiles que celui des
retraites qui est inéluctable car on
arrive à cette situation folle ou avec
des défenses comme celles auxquelles
nous assistons nous ne rendons pas
service aux Français parce que nous les
mettons dans une situation où les jeunes
générations vont payer pour les
générations actuelles que deuxièmement
ça va se faire par des déficits et
Jean-Claude Mahy pardon mais moi j'ai
une vraie divergence avec vous on fait
pas ça pour Bruxelles on fait ça parce
que c'est jamais bon un déficit parce
que il y a un moment où quand on en a
trop c'est pas la question de savoir si
on obéit à Bruxelles c'est comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour le faire payer
par les générations suivants
Bruxelles rappelle simplement des
glissières d'autoroute à Bruxelles les
gouvernements successifs ont accepté les
traités moi je suis européen c'est pas
de problème non mais c'est pas la
question mais reconnaissez que n'importe
quel gouvernement français aujourd'hui
compte tenu de ces engagements et obligé
de présenter un programme qui au bout de
cinq ans arrive à 3%. on est d'accord ce
programme même s'il est pas respecté
mais sauf que ce programme j'ai fait
l'exercice que je vous ai mis du budget
sauf que ce programme a été conçu pour
rappeler que c'est jamais bon stimuler
les dettes et les défis
parce que on a beaucoup de questions si
vous voulez et je voudrais quand même
avoir votre avis Michel Yaya les gens de
kervaser sur ce point précis faut-il oui
ou non une réforme des retraites
Jean-François Copé dit c'est
indispensable c'est le choix du
politique Jean-Claude Mahy ne dit pas ça
vous vous dites est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut une réforme oui moi je suis
convaincu que oui simplement il faut ne
pas mélanger les objectifs et je vais
faire
œuvre de réconciliation vous dites des
choses qui sont finalement assez
convenables Jean nous dit il y a
évidemment un gros problème
démographique comme dans tous les
systèmes de répartition puisque nous
payons aujourd'hui les retraites des
retraités d'aujourd'hui il y a donc
moins d'actifs
plus de retraités qui perçoivent plus
longtemps des retraites plus élevées un
gamin de CM2 comprendrait qu'un prennent
démographique ce problème démographique
il a une traduction économique voilà et
c'est lui qui fait que on consacre 14
points de PIB à la retraite et 10 à la
santé
si je peux juste terminer ma réponse je
dirais qu'il en faut une de réformes
pour des raisons d'abord macroéconomique
parce que 14 points de PIB c'est un prêt
macroéconomique pas un problème
financier de base et pas simplement lié
au contexte dans lequel la France se
débat comme d'autres mais je vais faire
plaisir à mon voisin de gauche si on
prend un peu d'altitude par rapport aux
grandes réformes sociales il me semble
que la réforme de la santé si on oublie
l'impératif économique et probablement
plus prégnante aujourd'hui et où là où
je vous suis volontiers monsieur le
ministre c'est que si on avait un peu de
temps à y consacrer ça serait pas mal
voilà un genre de car va se jouer
réforme nécessaire ou pas et
c'est une question arithmétique imagine
question Jean-Claude maillet qui était
pas du tout une question piège vraiment
une vraie question je ne comprends pas
comment les syndicats s'intéressent plus
aux inactif que actifs c'est-à-dire que
en fait ce poids il est payé par les
actifs les gens que vous représentez on
voit bien que ça a énormément de
conséquences et que l'année 2022 l'année
de croissance moi j'y crois pas beaucoup
et ça sera plutôt zéro au moins quelque
chose donc je ne comprends pas pourquoi
vous défendez autant
les éventuels actifs futures et inactif
futur et éventuels assez peu les actifs
je comprends pas non mais attendez on
défend on défend les deux regarde enfin
il faut ouvrir comment fonctionne aussi
système de retraite aujourd'hui
quand même que il y avait au moins pour
les salariés du privé il y a un régime
de base il y a des régimes de
complémentaires qui sont et je considère
que ce qu'on appelle le paritarisme dans
notre pays syndicat patronat et je
considère que la gestion paritaire n'a
pas démérités elle existe depuis 1947 48
pour les premiers pour les premiers
régimes paritaire qui reste dans
je considère même que moi je considère
pas que l'État est par définition
meilleure gestionnaire par définition et
je considère même que au fil du temps
quel que soit les gouvernements l'état
perd du pouvoir il a perdu du pouvoir
monétaire il a perdu en partie du
pouvoir budgétaire et on voit bien qu'il
y a une tentation forte de prendre la
main sur toute la sphère sociale on le
voit avec l'assurance chômage bon alors
il y a cette dimension derrière mais ça
ne concerne pas que les salariés
discuter avec les moi je discute
aujourd'hui avec les régimes de non
salariés que ce soit les avocats les
experts comptables les médecins etc tous
disent attendez mais on gère notre
système et ça marche pourquoi
rendez-vous prendre la main sur tout ça
donc moi je considère que les syndicats
d'une manière générale ne nous
concerne pas que les actifs je considère
même que c'est à la fois les actifs et
les retraités ils viennent de décider
moi j'ai plus de responsabilité
syndicale aucune aujourd'hui mais ils
viennent de décider d'une revalorisation
des retraites complémentaire du privé au
1er novembre de 5 et quelques pourcents
voilà ils font leur boulot mais on peut
pas dire que les syndicats ne s'occupent
que des actifs merci au revoir on va en
parler par Monsieur pardonnez-moi on va
en parler
[Musique]
monsieur Copé si je ne me trompe pas
vous avez été ministre du Budget alors
je voudrais vous poser une question que
les gens s'adressent
pas mais ça dépend de la boulangerie ça
dépend du territoire d'après le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites organismes
indépendants et incontesté les comptes
sont au vert pour 2021 et 2022 avec un
milliard de bénéfices enfin bénéfices
disons d'excédents financiers et 3
milliards en 2022 par contre on dit que
ça va se détériorer en 2023 2032 comment
vous expliquer ce yoyo financier et
est-ce que qui sait que ça va se
détériorer de cette manière-là est-ce
qu'on peut pas avoir ces mécanique il se
trouve que là nous avons eu deux entre
guillemets bonnes années du fait de la
reprise de l'activité boscovide c'est
uniquement pour ça il faut pas se
raconter d'histoires le déficit sur
cette branche là il est de toute façon
structurelle et il ne va jamais aller en
s'améliorant et d'ailleurs quand
Jean-Claude Mahy dit le l'État a perdu
de son pouvoir budgétaire pourquoi il a
perdu son pouvoir budgétaire parce qu'il
a tellement laissé filer les dépenses
qu'il n'a plus d'autre maîtrise de quoi
que ce soit il est obligé de passer son
temps à chercher comment les combler
c'est la différence avec l'Allemagne qui
est la toujours veillée avoir de
l'équilibre budgétaire et qui quand il y
a un gros coup de de tonnerre et ben il
CAPA très vite de réinvestir et on en a
la démonstration aujourd'hui ensuite
pour pour le reste le sujet de fond
c'est que le rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites ils sont
constants depuis des années et tous
disent la même chose attention cela va
se dégrader structurellement il peut y
avoir des bonnes années mais globalement
ça va se dégrader c'est inéluctable
c'est un appel au décideur politique
c'est pour ça que j'en reviens là tout à
l'heure ce genre de Douai il a posé une
question un petit peu pernicieuse
à Jean-Claude mahire lui disant mais
qu'est-ce que cette histoire maintenant
que vous occupez que des retraités la
vérité au lieu de vous occuper des
actifs mais pas du tout en vérité
d'ailleurs Jean-Claude maillet très bien
répondu comme il pouvait mais la vérité
c'est que non les partenaires sociaux
enfin les syndicats ils sont surtout
obsédés par la défense des actifs qui
pour beaucoup d'entre nous aucune envie
de d'augmenter le temps de travail parce
que personne n'a spontanément envie dans
une société qui faut bien le dire depuis
40 ans en tant toute la journée le
travail c'est mal le travail c'est moche
le travail c'est une pénalité etc bon
nous avons donc il faut pas s'y tromper
au-delà de l'allongement de la retraite
pour sauver le système et permettre
qu'on préserve cette répartition qui est
tellement consubstantielle à l'histoire
de France mais c'est aussi un nouveau
rapport au travail qui doit se mettre en
place et moi je pense que le seul débat
qu'on doit avoir sur l'allongement de la
retraite c'est est-ce c'est
l'employabilité de ce qu'on appelle pour
aller vite les seniors ça c'est dans le
détail des solutions il y a des
description il faut arrêter de dire
comme au-delà de 60 ans on n'est plus
employable on réformerait ça c'est en
réalité un argument d'autorité qui n'est
pas recevable quand on voit que tous les
autres pays d'Europe sont entre 64 65 66
67 ans
sur un point précis
l'argumentation syndicale consiste à
dire aujourd'hui il y a de l'argent pour
les retraites c'est pas sûr qu'il y en
aura pas vous contestez les prévisions
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
pour la Décennie 2023 2032 où vous
considérez que on sera déficitaire non
non je ne conteste pas les travaux du
corps quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs même
les prévisions pessimistes comment
fonctionne le corps pour les 5 années à
venir il prend comme base les prévisions
du gouvernement voilà donc le prévision
du gouvernement c'est quoi aujourd'hui
c'est 5% de chômage après il consulte un
panel d'économistes une quinzaine pour
les évolutions futures et les quinzaine
d'économistes considéraient qu'on sera
un taux de chômage de 7%. donc faut
faire la jonction entre 5 et 7 ce qui
que c'est traduit mécaniquement par un
déficit budgétaire alors mais le corps
fait son travail très correctement moi
je ne conteste pas que il y a des
difficultés financières etc y compris ce
domaine de la retraite et vous savez si
vous demandez la population qui est pour
un recul de la retraite les premiers qui
sont pour c'est les retraités puisqu'ils
sont en retraite donc ils ont pas de
problème pour reculer l'âge de la
retraite non je conteste pas ce que je
dis enfin moi je fais souvent référence
à Kens là-dessus seule chose dont on est
sur un moyen long terme c'est qu'on sera
tous morts les prévisions à 10-15 ans
attention voilà faut être relatif on est
à l'abri de d'aucune mais je ne conteste
pas qu'il y a un problème de financement
y compris d'ailleurs pour les retraités
parce que si on ne fait rien le taux de
remplacement il est passé déjà de 80% à
67 et demain il sera 50 donc c'est un
ensemble il faut réfléchir et là où je
suis d'accord avec Jean-François Copé
que le premier problème à discuter je
n'en ai pas six mois après le premier
problème à discuter c'est la perception
et l'évolution du travail c'est vrai
pour l'emploi des seniors mais c'est
vrai que y compris avec une accélération
avec la crise sanitaire la perception du
travail aujourd'hui de l'organisation du
travail etc est en train de changer
fondamentalement donc faut prendre ça on
considération y compris pour discuter
d'un dossier comme juste un truc
excusez-moi mais on est à six mois après
pourquoi on est à six mois après parce
qu'en réalité c'est un deuxième
quinquennat et c'est un compte à rebours
plus le temps va passer moins monsieur
Macron aura d'autorité pour faire les
choses exactement donc plus vite oui ce
sera décidé mieux ce sera juste un mot
tout à l'heure moi je ne les candidats à
la présidentielle font leur programme
etc mais croire un seul instant que les
gens apprennent les programmes par cœur
des uns et des autres
projets
oui il y a une autre manière de voir le
même sujet qui est de se dire quels sont
les alternatives face à mes 14 points
PIB et au déséquilibre macroéconomique
qu'on sait se situer dans les 10-15
prochaines années avec ce petit rebond
de deux ans qui est une poire pour la
soif mais une petite poire pour une
grande
soifs
première variante vous augmentez les
cotisations
des salariés ou des fonctionnaires donc
des actifs et ou des employeurs bon
enthousiasme général des deux côtés
voilà il fait macroéconomique
c'est-à-dire mais c'est une variante 50%
de prélèvements obligatoires sur pipe je
propose qu'on évacue des bas tout de
suite
la deuxièmement vous rogner les
avantages des retraités actuels ça passe
par des revalorisations la réforme
Balladur de 93 qui a été la plus
productive financièrement de toutes les
réformes des retraites avaient fait
passer d'un indice qui était
les salaires à un autre indice qui était
les prix la revalorisation des pensions
et pour des effets mécaniques que j'ai
pas le temps de décrire ça il y a un
double effet kiss cool dans le système
de retraite qui fait que là vous avez
vraiment une chute des dépenses une
économie très forte veut-on s'en prendre
si je puis dire aux retraités et
troisième possibilité
vous
touchez la première pas la seconde vous
faites vous prenez des mesures d'âge
quelle qu'elle soit parce que légal il y
a l'allongement de la durée d'assurance
de cotisation etc et là vous touchez
toujours aux assurer mais vous assurer
qu'ils sont par définition les plus
proches de la retraite donc à mon sens
le débat je sais pas s'il est politique
philosophiques ou tout ça à la fois il
doit être là-dessus il est pas sûr à ton
besoin de ressources nouvelles pour le
système parce que il m'étonnerait que on
se met tous d'accord pour baisser de 14
à 10 points de PIB la dépense de
retraite c'est par quel canaux il est
raisonnable de rééquilibrer le système
pour que nos enfants est encore un peu
de croyance dans sa pérennité parce que
moi un des trucs qui me soucie je sais
pas si vous avez eu ces études qui sont
récurrentes c'est que les jeunes de
moins de 30 ans disons quel que soit
leur milieu social professionnel ne
crois pas un seul instant qui toucheront
un euro de la retraite publique enfin du
système de répartition lorsqu'ils
arriveront à l'âge de liquider leur
pension ce qui à mon avis un peu
préoccupant oui alors je vais vous
laisser après
le recul de l'âge légal ah bah moi
personnellement projet mais dans un
cadre plus général merveilleusement il
ne reste plus que ça
alors écoutez on va rentrer dans le
détail je vous demanderai de voir de
nous dire qu'elle est qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire mais il y a un élément que je
voudrais éclaircir avec Jean de kervas
Doué parce que Jean vous occupez à la
fois des questions de santé des
questions d'économie si on prend
l'argument syndical et notamment celui
de la CFDT mais aussi d'infos la CGT ils
font un procès au gouvernement de
vouloir affecter d'éventuels recettes
provenant du contre retraite sur les
comptes sociaux vous voyez que
Jean-Claude Mahy est en train d'opiner
et de transférer ces ressources sur la
santé ou l'éducation première question
que je vous pose c'est finalement
pourquoi ce ne serait pas fondé et
pourquoi ce serait illogique de le faire
au regard du poids des retraites sur les
comptes sociaux de la nation puisque les
retraites c'est quand même le premier
poste de dépense de la protection
sociale alors quelle est cet argument
syndical voyez qui consiste à dire
finalement c'est pas la réforme des
retraites qui veulent faire mais sous
trouver des rustines pour mettre de
l'argent sur la santé et l'éducation
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez alors je
pense que Jean-Claude maillet il a dit
tout à l'heure ça avoir une histoire du
paritarisme c'est-à-dire le seul domaine
où il reste un semblant de paretarisme
sont les retraites néanmoins
je redis avec force ce que j'ai déjà dit
nous sommes dans une situation
démographique très particulière qui ne
va pas s'arranger parce que le troisième
âge donc est l'âge de la dépendance nous
ne sommes pas du tout prêts à faire face
à la dépendance de la génération du
baby-boom donc comme vous voyez un plfs
à plus 2% sur les dépenses de santé
alors que l'inflation
normal sans vieillissement c'est plutôt
4 et demi on va voir que ça va avoir
énormément de conséquences donc il est
d'autant plus urgent de régler ce
problème de retraite que les autres
dépensent social vont continuer vont
continuer de croire et moi je suis très
très inquiet de notre imprépation
à la dépendance je vous rappelle que
pour former un médecin il faut 10 ans
donc c'est pas avec les médecins ou en
lâchant le numérique clausus qu'on va
régler les problèmes de la prise en
charge des personnes âgées alors je
signerai par ailleurs quelque chose
qu'on appelle évoqué c'est en fait une
turpitude que j'ignorais c'est une de
mes amis qui va attirer mon attention
c'est que en fait
les régimes de retraite sont financés en
partie de manière cachée alors dans le
privé elles sont financées par des
cotisations agées à Arco 28% simplement
la cnrsl c'est 48%, il faut
comment tu dis 35 35 oui bon c'est
beaucoup
les retraites des fonctionnaires 185 et
les militaires 640 donc tu as une sur
cotisation
c'est à dire que l'État sur finance le
système de retraite par un système
fiscal dont personne ne débarquement
sociale oui non mais autrement dit si tu
avais un débat c'est 28% pour tout le
monde il manque 45 milliards
sur ce point-là sur ce point là
Jean-François Copé comme ça je suis
quelque chose d'assez connu quand on
plonge un peu dans l'univers très
complexe du financement des retraites et
c'est inévitable mais c'est ça fait
partie de partir du moment multiplier
les régimes spéciaux où vous faites en
plus du régime de base des régimes
complémentaires dont vous confiez pour
certains d'entre eux la gestion des
organismes tiers vous êtes donc des
organismes publics aussi imminent que la
caisse vous êtes assuré d'avoir
effectivement dans tous les sens des
mécanismes fiscaux de redistribution
pour tenir comme on peut c'est pour ça
que moi lorsque j'étais plus jeune pour
tous vous confier j'étais très allant
sur le thème faisons tout d'un coup
c'est à dire on simplifie on fait un
seul régime on met tout le monde
d'équerre liberté égalité fraternité un
peu modèle Mélenchon mais le bon côté du
mélenchonisme et pas le mauvais
finalement j'ai besoin un effort je
viens d'en trouver un depuis deux ans
je vous rassure tout de suite mais la
réalité c'est que
on y arrivera pas parce que ça c'est
trop et je pense que on ne peut pas
ouvrir tous les fronts d'un coup donc je
reste à cette idée que la seule mesure
possible c'est la mesure d'âge je
voudrais d'ailleurs comprendre je vais
vous dire on va arriver à cette chose
juste une fois Édouard Philippe échoué
enfin le gouvernement de Monsieur Macron
c'est pas lui bien sûr parce que il y
avait encore trop de choses et parmi ces
choses là il y avait la retraite à point
tout le monde était en panique je pense
encore une fois qu'il faut une décision
simple qui va permettre au moins de
s'inscrire dans la durée
[Musique]
alors on en vient justement à la
question
du programme et de ce qu'on peut faire
les évolutions sont imprévisibles
notamment avec la transition énergétique
la transition numérique mais le
vieillissement est là et concernant les
retraites si vous avez à imaginer
tous les quatre d'ailleurs
quel pourrait être
une situation durable et non démagogique
comment vous mélangez tous les
ingrédients à savoir les cotisations
l'âge de départ
les seniors qui ont un problème ou en
partie les compensations pour les femmes
etc c'est quoi votre modèle Jean-Claude
Mahy imaginons que vous êtes là vous
agitez des algorithmes et vous faites
votre retraite c'est quoi on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps rassuré
je ne dis pas que le régime actuel est
parfait moi je ne d'abord je viens
bouger quoi et vous ne bougez quoi voilà
je conserverai une souplesse pas
simplement le paritariste à dit qu'à
patrona mais aussi les professions
libérales gèrent aussi correctement pour
la plupart d'entre elles leur régime de
retraite et ça fait une souplesse quoi
bon on a bien vu qu'avec le régime par
point tout mettre ça marchait pas quoi
c'est un beau truc sur le papier
complètement irréaliste sur le plan
pragmatique moi peut-être vos surprendre
mais moi je pense aussi qu'on alors sur
l'âge moi je dis arrêtons de faire des
faux débats on est déjà dans les faits
pour la génération 73 à 64 ans dans les
faits ce sera le cas la génération née
en 73 je le rappelle qui a commencé à
cotiser à 21 ans ce qui sera pas le cas
tout le monde 43 ans de cotisation vous
faites le total on pourrait très bien
imaginer certains le pensent des
formules de la règle des 105 par exemple
aujourd'hui ça veut dire aujourd'hui
vous avez 43 ans de cotisation et un âge
de 62 62 et 43 105 dès que vous avez 105
vous pouvez partir vous réglez une
partie du problème des carrières longues
par exemple et là où je vais peut-être
vous surprendre c'est que dans le
système public des fonctionnaires il y a
un système qui a été mis en place le
rafle le régime additionnel de la
fonction publique un système par
capitalisation qui est sur les primes
moi je ne serai pas compte un troisième
niveau obligatoire par capitalisation
mais obligatoire parce que vous avez
beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui
le pratiquent mais vous avez vous êtes
dans une PME vous ne l'avez pas alors on
va dire il y a le plan d'épargne
retraite mais c'est autre chose encore
on pourrait très bien négocier par
branche la mise en place de tel système
etc il existe avec la Gifi par exemple
c'est ce qui existe avec la gipi par
exemple non oui non notamment mais un
peu ce qui existe dans la fonction
publique un régime additionnel dans le
privé un troisième on garde les deux
niveaux vous avez des caisses de non
salarié qui fonctionnent les pharmaciens
ils ont depuis 1950 un système par
capitalisation qui marche très bien
voilà après il y a les règles à mettre
en place pour pas faire n'importe quoi
je suis d'accord mais voilà ce que vous
fait penser qu'est-ce que vous faites
pour les seniors alors ah bah les
seniors attendez on a on a ça s'améliore
parce que quand on recule l'âge de
départ progressivement l'emploi des
seigneurs ça veut dire mais on est
encore beaucoup beaucoup en retard après
il y a tous les systèmes de prêt-à-tête
progressive de tutorat de il faut il
faut
doit intervenir pour mettre un peu
contraintes entre guillemets les
entreprises à conserver plus les
salariés diag on vous a entendu alors
Jean de kervas doué en dehors de l'âge
de départ à 65 ans ou pas sur quoi vous
considérez qu'il faut bouger aujourd'hui
donc je pense que 65 ans n'est pas bon
calcul mais je pense que et je partage
la sagesse autour de cette table
c'est-à-dire que c'est la seule chose
qu'on puisse faire et dire aujourd'hui
ce qui compte pour moi c'est l'espérance
de vie à partir du moment on prend sa
retraite c'est à dire que donc c'est la
solidarité entre les actifs et les
inactifs alors comme vous le savez nous
avons le record mondial d'espérance de
vie à la retraite
donc on pourrait se caler sur cette
bonne nouvelle
qui est que l'espérance il y a très
fortement augmenté pour tout le monde
même s'il y a des très fortes inégalités
et
s'ajuster sur ce paramètre sachant que
ces paramètres changera en 2050 ou 2060
et que on aura du fait de la disparition
de la génération de baby-boom une
signature démographique très différente
de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui et où
Michel yayel quels ingrédients vous
accompagnerez dame modification
éventuelle de l'âge de de départ à la
retraite qu'est-ce que vous verriez
comme
assortiment qui viendrait
féconder une réforme des retraites c'est
le cas de le dire
moi si vous voulez si je pars du système
chimiquement pur qui était au départ le
projet
présidentiel
négocié discuter construit par l'équipe
de le voir
j'ai toujours pensé on en avait discuté
à l'époque qu'il était un peu trop
ambitieux si je puis dire en largeur et
en hauteur alors je m'explique en
largeur
il aurait fallu des camps de base avant
de passer de 42 à 1 on pouvait peut-être
travailler par famille et des familles
il y en a trois il y a l'essentiel les
salariés avec la sécurité sociale et
l'art coagir les professions
indépendantes qui sont assez différentes
les unes des autres mais qui ont quand
même beaucoup de points communs dans
leur modalités de gestion et puis les
agents publics fonctionnaires et
contractuel de trois fonctions publiques
et si ces trois pôles là avaient déjà
d'une certaine manière organisée les
choses en interne il restait c'est un
chemin compliqué mais enfin il restait à
faire quelque chose de sur ce chemin
moins escarpé qui aurait été de les
rassembler in fine
en hauteur
moi ça fait longtemps que qui me semble
que pour l'avenir mais l'avenir étant
maintenant probablement un peu compromis
ce qu'on aurait pu universaliser ce sont
déjà les régimes de base parce que ça
les Français leur ont compris même si ça
aurait peut-être occasionné des
frottements et là la difficulté ça a été
qu'on a voulu englober les régimes
complémentaires alors le navire amiral
qui est des régimes complémentaires de
salariés alors quoi dire que c'est pas
n'importe quoi Jean-Claude la rappeler
il y en a aussi des régimes
complémentaires dans le secteur public
il y en a beaucoup dans le secteur des
professions indépendantes ça faisait
quand même beaucoup de trucs à régler
d'un seul coup d'un seul et de la même
manière que devant chaque niche fiscale
il y a un chien qui aboie devant chaque
régime particulier c'est pas un chien
mais enfin il y a en tout cas une
corporation une profession un
sous-ensemble de la société tout à fait
respectable qui se manifeste donc si on
veut réenclencher à l'avenir moi je ne
sais pas quand mais un jour non pas
l'idée du régime universel mais l'idée
disons d'un rapprochement d'une
consolidation d'une uniformisation des
régimes de retraite ça pourrait être une
voie je vous rappelle que
Pierre Laroque disait la sécurité
sociale repose sur les trois u
l'universalité l'unité l'uniformité
l'universalité on l'a fait dans la
branche famille et la branche maladie on
l'a pas fait dans la branche vieillesse
l'unité c'est un seul régime je pense
qu'on en est un peu loin et l'uniformité
on a progressé parce que les réformes
des gouvernements antérieurs quel qu'ils
aient été on concouru quand même à ce
que les règles soient moins opposés
qu'elle ne l'était avant autrement dit
et j'arrête là il sera difficile d'aller
dans ce chemin de l'unité et de
l'uniformité mais le chemin est moins
long à faire que ce qu'il aurait été si
on s'était lancé là dedans dans les
années 70-80 c'est un motif
c'est pas une question politique c'est
pas le terme natif avec la mesure d'âge
c'est pas une question politique
je vais vous poser la même question à
savoir vous avez dit que vous êtes
favorable à un âge de départ à 65 ans
mais à votre avis si le président de la
République vous consultez et vous disais
qu'est-ce que vous maîtriez à côté de
cet âge de départ ce serait quoi si je
puis dire ce qui viendrait et est-ce que
vous conseilleriez dans ce cas-là à vos
amis politiques de voter une telle
réforme c'est sûr
premier point ce qui consulte
c'est pas l'ambiance monsieur Macron
c'est pas quelqu'un qui spontanément
écoute vraiment j'aimerais vraiment
avoir Jacques Chirac faisait ça mais bon
les temps ont changé c'était du temps où
les chanteurs avaient de la voix
en réalité pour moi le problème il est
il est à la fois simple
parce qu'on a tellement éprouvé la
complexité des situations qu'on est
arrivé une conclusion assez simple et en
même temps elle nécessite que sur tous
ces sujets on trouvait évidemment les
accompagnants bon les accompagnants il
faut pas qu'il y en ait 36 il faut qu'il
soit simple aussi la mesure majeure
c'est le report de l'âge légal c'est pas
que je le sens
pour qu'on comprenne bien c'est pas mon
souhait c'est pas mon choix c'est une
évidence c'est c'est
factuel donc on a même pas à voir une
opinion on n'a pas le choix en vérité
vous la sortissez de ces premiers points
le deuxième point c'est qu'il faut la
sortir de trois mesures qui a mes yeux
sont absolument essentielles la première
c'est évidemment de s'occuper des
petites retraites et eux il faut les et
tous ceux qui ont des retraites en
dessous d'un certain soit il faut
impérativement les revaloriser de
manière régulière parce que là on est
sur des minimum de survie
donc ça c'est le premier la première
mesure d'accompagnement la deuxième bah
oui évidemment qu'il faut assumer
d'avoir un régime de capitalisation en
plus dans les entreprises dans les
administrations que tout ça soit naturel
et qu'on arrête de hurler au capitalisme
et au mondialisme c'est le bon sens tous
les pays du monde le font et c'est une
sécurité supplémentaire pour les
Français bon et puis la troisième mesure
c'est que ce qui marche bien on le
laisse marcher quoi les régimes des
indépendants fonctionne globalement bien
quel est l'intérêt de les noyer dans les
régimes qui ne marchent pas du tout
laissons les tranquilles donc si on fait
tout ça en fait c'est simple c'est
accessible ça va faire grincer mais à la
fin de la journée au moins il y aura au
moins ça dans le bilan politique
d'Emmanuel Macron sinon je suis désolé
de le dire mais il va être très pauvre
le bilan politique et donc là où sous
monsieur Chirac sous Monsieur Sarkozy et
même sous Monsieur Hollande ce qui est
quand même pas gagné au départ ça a été
il y a eu quelque chose là il n'y a rien
donc c'est pas si il y a ça mais non
seulement c'est votable mais il faut
même faire campagne pour et c'est là où
puisque vous me posez la question moi ça
fait des mois je suis très seul je suis
allé rares indiens avec Sarkozy si
c'était pour une fois on est d'accord
sur un sujet c'est qu'effectivement on
est les deux seuls à dire mais qu'est-ce
qu'attend LR pour redevenir un parti de
gouvernement qui gouverne comment est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on s'oppose sans
faire rire tous les Français sur des
sujets compris préconise depuis des
années donc oui bien sûr il faut non
seulement voter si c'est ça la réforme
mais il faut soutenir il faut faire
campagne contre et il ne faut pas
craindre de s'opposer à Madame Le Pen
qui veut être président de la République
et qui nous explique qu'il faut surtout
pas réformer les retraites ou à Monsieur
Mélenchon et tout l'orchestre qui est
alors eux sont dans le délire intégral
en expliquant qu'il y a absolument aucun
autre sujet que celui de renverser par
la rue la France ça sera tellement mieux
après donc franchement c'est le bon sens
même de prendre ces dispositions qui
nous redonnerons quand même de la
crédibilité vis-à-vis des Français bon
ben écoutez vous êtes ceux qui sont
contre
fait vos propositions les uns et les
autres Jean-Claude
reprendre la question de Jean de kervas
Douai sur les actifs et les inactifs
mais en essayant de la prolonger parler
des retraites
c'est fatalement parler du travail c'est
à dire de la fin du travail de la fin
d'un cycle pour vous comme pour moi
comme pour tous nos intervenants et tous
les Français est-ce que vous pensez pas
c'est plus de la sociologie politique
qu'une question est-ce que vous pensez
pas qu'à force de parler des retraites
par anticipation c'est la valeur travail
qui est remise en cause
que je vous pose cette question là parce
que on s'est posé la même question avec
la réduction du temps de travail et on
s'est posé la question est-ce que ça n'a
pas atteint la valeur travail donc vous
voyez je suis pas pour le débat va leur
travail droit à la paresse quoi je veux
dire droit à paresse c'est 19e siècle
faut aussi voilà
non mais par contre il y a une vraie
évolution aujourd'hui et on doit
travailler là-dessus un certain propose
des Assises du travail je pense que
c'est une nécessité aujourd'hui la
perception même du travail accélérée
avec la crise sanitaire si vous par
exemple la crise sanitaire génère de
nouvelles inégalités on retrouve une
inégalité col blanc colle bleue ceux qui
peuvent télétravailler ceux qui ne
peuvent pas compte tenu de leur fonction
comment on règle ça moi je sais que
certains entreprises arrivent à régler
ça bon des jeunes candidats ou des
cadres candidats etc une des premières
questions qui posent aujourd'hui c'est
combien de jours télétravail voilà donc
le sens la question du tout ça joue il
faut envisager également le travail sur
une période beaucoup plus longue c'est
pas simplement une question de durée
hebdomadaire c'est aussi sur la vie donc
tout ça doit être discuté il y a
vraiment des évolutions à prendre en
considération et c'est pour ça que je
dis la vraie si on avait le temps la
vraie réflexion c'est d'abord là-dessus
après on discute des conséquences y
compris sur la retraite y compris avec
les faux débats qu'on peut avoir sur la
enfin quand il faut débat je m'entends
je disais dans les faits on est déjà 64
qui est bientôt donc arrêtons de tirer
des plans sur la comète quoi bon en tout
cas ça devrait pas poser de problème que
tout le monde soit d'accord pour l'âge
légal à 65 non enfin même Sarko il dit
63 dans le jdda ce weekend
Sarkozy
Sarkozy c'est pas bonnet blanc bonnet
vous savez bien oui je voudrais bien
parce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
un ensemble on peut pas 64 on peut pas
uniquement raisonner à âge c'est un
ensemble on vous a un travail est perçu
différemment mais vous vous sentez qu'il
y a un risque de
d'hypothéquer le sens du travail
ça évolue énormément il y a quelque
chose qui moi monsieur si beaucoup c'est
l'abandon des métiers du soin
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui dans les
hôpitaux de Paris et pas seulement
l'Assistance publique on règle les
programmes opératoires sur la présence
d'infirmière donc il y a en gros dans
les hôpitaux de Paris il y a une vague
20% du personnel soignant qu'on n'arrive
pas à recruter donc si on pose pas la
question du travail
et de certains travailleurs
là dessus Michel yayel parce qu'on est
vraiment pris par le temps un mot là
dessus oui je voudrais juste un mot en
un mot
que en 1995 quand il s'agissait de
passer ou pas par la suite au 35 heures
on était un certain nombre notamment
avec Bernard brune disparu depuis à
s'être dit ça serait finalement pas mal
de troquer un allongement de la durée de
travail dans la carrière là je les gale
avec un raccourcissement de la durée
hebdomadaire du travail en somme la
réforme des retraites versus les 35
heures le fait d'avoir fait l'un après
l'autre nous a plutôt fait cumuler les
ennuis merci écoutez on va terminer sur
une note d'humour mais on a très peu de
temps
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment d'après
Albert Thibaudet le retraitée
et comme le bouilleur de cru un
personnage éminemment français est-ce
que vous y souscrivez Jean-François Copé
on voudrait qu'il existe longtemps quand
même merci
le travail et la plaie les classes qui
boivent voilà
je suis fasciné par le travail je peux
rester devant lui pendant des heures
merci bien vous voyez que ça nous amène
le travail la retraite nous amène à
avoir un peu d'humour une bibliographie
rapide de Pierre-Edouard Ducret retraite
l'impossible réforme c'est une analyse
de la réforme des retraites Jean de
kervas Doué alors je signale un dernier
livre mais qui n'a pas voir encore que
les écolos nous mentent vous restez
là-dessus c'est pas trop impératif non
c'est très sous-estime très sous-estime
bon
Jean-Claude Mahy Jean-Claude Mahy manif
et chuchotement vous continuez à
chuchoter dans votre syndicat un petit
peu un petit peu et je voudrais rappeler
que le dernier ouvrage pas si c'est le
dernier Jean-François Copé le sursaut
français vous pensez que c'est toujours
d'actualité Jean-François
du bouc émissaire qui était
des grands problèmes de notre pays on
avait toujours des bonnes raisons de
dire que c'était la faute de quelqu'un
d'autre voilà mais à côté on va rester
là je vous remercie merci messieurs
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
à l'équipe de LCP avant de nous quitter
je vous soumet cette citation de
Philippe Geluck si Dieu était tenu de
prendre sa retraite à 65 ans je
deviendrai peut-être croyant
[Musique]